the Joe Rogan experience when you hear
an origin story like the one where you
were talking about people coming out of
the earth mm-hmm how do you decipher
that well I've actually been to that
origin site and it it looks like a
female it's a place where we were
birthed it looks like a female what it
looks like a place where we were we were
birthed out of Mother Earth
it's a beautiful amazing and almost
shocking place where is this place this
is in Mississippi so you think that that
might be true that's that's our origin
story or that's one of our origin
stories right but you understand how
scientifically that would be a real
problem right people coming out of the
ground like like poppies maybe maybe not
maybe not I think there are there are
stories and narratives that were no
longer connected with and our lives
today are so out of context with the
natural world that we don't know what's
possible anymore
we've been so separated from that even
to imagine yeah but we have a clear line
from ancient hominids to modern human
beings that science has been able to
piece together
mm-hmm that's one that's one story right
that's a story and other stories we came
out of the ground like roses mm-hmm do
you think that's possible don't that
seems highly unlikely look if I give you
if you had money to bet I give you a
thousand bucks and you could put it on
this or that you could put it on well
we've probably people got here by all
sorts of means the way people got
everywhere by all sorts of means or they
came out of the ground like flowers or
Adam and Eve and all that other these
stories whether there are origin stories
that they create our identity they
create who we are at the center of our
being and they have lessons to teach us
and they also remind us
what we're responsible for and that's
what I'm saying that we've been so
separated from that part of us in our
connection to the natural world and to
the earth right so we're a part of the
earth we're a part of come from the
earth whether or not we actually born on
the ground is we're really well we're
responsible for it so we were put in
certain places to be responsible and
care take for that area so a lot of
these stories what they're they're
essentially trying to connect people
with the idea that they are part of this
great earth they're part of this
beautiful ecosystem and maybe this
origin story is devised to sort of
explain to them in a way that makes a
clear connection mm-hmm does that make
sense
no absolutely absolutely but but but
it's but it's part of who many tribal
nations are this is our place this is
our homeland this is what we're
responsible for and we haven't been able
to do what we were put here to do our
purpose has been ripped away from us so
so a lot of the work we do is to try to
you know work towards environmental
healing and try to bring lands back into
our land holdings so that we can care
take for that land that's not that's not
all over Indian country there's there
are some places in Indian country that
that extract oil and and do things that
that could be harmful for the
environment you know and and we do what
we can is you know with what we got
and nations are sovereign the tribes are
sovereign so they get to decide what's
best for them and whether they're going
to be sustainable or not
[Applause]